the surgeon general of the united states
said friday he imagines a future when
covett is treated like any other
respiratory virus but he did not put a
timeline on when that might happen and
noted that there are still hurdles ahead
his comments come as 2300 people a day
died from covid over the past week in
the country michael george is here with
the latest michael good morning dana
good morning a lot of states are now
rolling back mask mandates as
hospitalizations and new cases decline
but health experts are reminding
americans this pandemic isn't over yet
as thousands are still dying daily and a
new report came out yesterday on the
long-term effectiveness of booster shots
new cdc data shows booster shots given
four months ago or more may lose
effectiveness in preventing
hospitalizations and emergency room
visits from around 90 percent uh two
months after the boost which is gray
versus now 60 to 70 percent after four
or five months
and so the question is will this
continue to decline that question came
as vaccines for children under five
received a setback friday when federal
regulators said it needed more data to
show pfizer's three dose vaccine is
effective i see this as a sign that our
regulators are on top of this only 23
percent of children ages 5 to 11 in the
u.s are fully vaccinated and nearly 57
percent of 12 to 17 year olds have had
at least two doses vaccines remained the
linchpin for a return to life as we knew
it in 2019 according to u.s surgeon
general dr vivek murthy we are going to
need the tools that we've been building
over the last year we're going to need
readily available not vaccines and
therapeutics we're going to need those
freely available high quality masks and
tests and we're going to also need the
right mindset recognizing that covet is
not going to disappear overnight that
mindset may not fit with a school mask
proposal by georgia's governor which
would give parents not school districts
or states the final say on whether kids
wear them or not nobody seems to be
following the data and the science
anymore they're following the politics
so a lot of parents are asking when will
the vaccine be approved for children
under five well it'll likely be until at
least april that's when pfizer says
it'll have more data on the vaccine's
effectiveness for young kids michelle
michael thank you